chers amis nous allons assister à la
première course individuelle du biathlon
de chars d'assaut
la première division les gladiateurs de
chartres la république du bélarus la
serbie la zerda et jean la chine et la
république populaire de chine
nous allons insister à cette série je
souhaite à tous une très bonne humeur et
pour éviter la propagation de duke au
vide et je vous prie de garder une
distance sociale dans ma très demi de
porter un masque élégant l'avait plus
souvent venant utiliser les
antiseptiques si vous sentez les
symptômes de la maladie
alors saisissez le prochain
collaborateur de notre forum nous vous
souhaitons à tous une très bonne santé
[Musique]
cher ami tu as dû ce champ de tir dallas
bino dans quelques secondes dans quatre
minutes et nous allons commencer le 1er
tour du biathlon de chars d'assaut 2020
nous invitons tous à prendre leur place
sur la tribune
nous avons les équipages de la chine
d'azerbaïdjan de la serbie et de la
biélorussie qui participent à ce tour ce
sont d'autres très forte équipe et c'est
la biélorussie qui s'est classé deuxième
l'année dernière et les équipages sont
ont déjà pris leurs positions de départ
et cette course individuelle va
s'étendre sur l'ensemble de cette
semaine ensuite procédant à la demi
finale
la course relais infinie finalement la
finale 400 accepterons nous serons le
vainqueur 1-2 ce tournoi l'an dernier
nous avons pris la décision de diviser
les équipant de partir de division cette
année nous avons seize équipes
participant au tournoi de biathlon de
chars il ya dans chaque division hui
équipe à la russie et placés dans la
division numéro un et ses équipages vont
continuer à participer au tournoi dans
les jours qui viennent et donc d'après
les résultats qu'ils ont montré ils vont
être attribués à telle ou telle
catégorie et notamment la demi finale
alors chers amis nous sommes en direct
de las vegas je suis nicolaï federov
commentateurs je vous invite à prendre
vos classes sur le tribune dans quelques
minutes cette série ce tour pas commencé
nous voyons beaucoup de supporters sur
ce champ de tir dallas bino qui sont
venus pour supporter leur équipe payer
représente les pays participants et tous
les invités je voudrais saluer elle pu
eux aussi et tous les spectateurs qui
nous suivent en direct et sur internet
sur les plateformes médiatiques les plus
diverses aides dans n'importe quelle
partie du monde vous pouvez suivre ce
tournoi qui ne fait que gagner en
popularité et
qui regroupe les meilleurs équipages de
chars du monde entier alors je vais vous
rappeler brièvement les règles de ce
byatt long c'est une course individuelle
chaque équipage concours
individuellement et aujourd'hui nous
avons la chine de serbie les airbags
gens et la biélorussie alors ils vont
faire trois tours vous pouvez voir
l'itinéraire de ce tournoi grâce au
tracker gps installés sur les chars nous
allons pouvoir suivre la position de
chaque char sur son itinéraire
d'ailleurs mon procédons à tir sur cible
numéro 12 à une distance 1600 1700 et
1800 m et d'après les règles établies
pour la première division cette année
si une cible est manquée les équipages
vont utiliser des munitions
supplémentaires
vous devez le charger et ensuite
procéder à nouveau à ce tir comme ça
nous allons pouvoir craint montrer la
puissance du feu le tir de combat
la précision qui ont le plus
d'importance dans ce concours
alors la cible numéro 12 qui est limite
en charge
ensuite il va falloir surmonter des
obstacles ensuite position de tir sur la
cible numéro de cinq hélicoptères et
ensuite un troisième partie du tournoi
un tir de la mitrailleuse coillte sial
sur la cible numéro 9 c'est un rpg
et ensuite le constructeur du char va
devoir à surmonter tous les obstacles et
terminer la course le champion de
l'année dernière était l'équipe de la
fédération de russie s'est classée 2e
l'équipe de la biélorussie et la
troisième la sélection du kazakhstan bon
on va voir ce que cette année va nous
apporter et cette année pour la première
fois le biathlon de chars d'assaut sont
organisés en parallèle avec le ferons
militaro-technique repartent patriotes
et dans le cadre de ce forum militaro
militaire internationale 2 à partir de
demain et jusqu'à samedi le commandant
de l'enfant tripous de russie va vous
montrer les capacités du matériel qui
sont actuellement qui est actuellement
utilisé par les forces armées russes
donc vous pouvez voir andrei me crasher
vite et république du nil y allait
réussir à des adieux beach serbie à
l'azerbaïdjan s'acquitte berdyev est la
chine colonel
si l'insigne en conformité avec le
résultat du tirage au sort les juges
sont sélectionnés à nouveau pour chaque
tournoi est bien sûr on peut pas juger
son propre pays
on peut pas être arbitre de son propre
pays
donc après ce tour elle les arbitres
vont inspecter toutes les sites ou les
cibles
bien sûr il ya des
des défaillances techniques parfois mais
il ya aussi des cas où la caméra ne puis
ne donne pas la possibilité de voir si
la cible a été vraiment
attentes dans ce cas là les arbitres
elle les inspecte physiquement eux mêmes
ensuite il ya un collège de guîtres où
la principale de la compétition générale
majeur romande benioff tillon consultent
tous les autres les arbitres tous les
autres et consultant technique que pour
savoir s'il ya eu une défaillance
technique à l'heure tous les détails
sont examinés et c'est après cette
inspection la plus profonde de cette
consultation la plus profonde que le
résultat est attribué donc vous voyez
l'équipage de serbie qui est prêt à
commencer à concourir nos voyants ses
supporters elle les serbes
chers amis alors c'est toujours les
premiers qui ont la peau plus de
difficultés de commencer parce que pour
montrer un bon résultat ensuite vous
voyez l'équipage de la chine cet
équipage est tout à fait nouveau tous
les participants de ce tour de cette
série là sont de nouveau
participants il participe pour la
première fois va pouvoir voir les
supporters de la chine
vous voyez maintenant l'équipage
d'azerbaidjan et les supporters
désherbage gens qui s'apprêtent à suivre
de près la compétition de leur équipe
ensuite l'équipe de la biélorussie alors
je vous prie d'applaudir elle effraie
fera nos frères biélorusse mais bien
évidemment nous sommes amis avec tous
les pays et nous avons des relations de
partenariat et de fraternité aussi avec
pas mal de pays alors
on finit les préparatifs du champ de tir
après la série précédente
et d'ici quelques secondes nous allons
commencer la première le premier tour du
biathlon de chars d'assaut et pour le 5
septembre nous allons aussi le 170 nous
allons assister à la finale la finale de
la seconde division sociale fera un peu
avant et ceux qui participent à la
deuxième division peuvent passer à la
première et s'il montre de bons
résultats cette année nous allons tirer
le bilan et les équipes seront réparties
en division en conformité avec le les
résultats de l'année 2020
[Musique]
alors je vous rappelle que la course
individuelle est une épreuve très
dynamique il faut surmonter pas mal
d'obstacles ce qui prend 30 minutes à
peu près mais pour s'en souvenir des
ultras des années précédentes je vous
serez vous notez que l'équipage de la
chine a montré les meilleurs résultats
l'an dernier c'était 18 minutes et ils
se sont classés troisièmes à la cotation
à la notation en général
ensuite à l'azerbaïdjan avec 42 minutes
ils ont détruit tous les cibles ensuite
la serbie 23 minutes à mai mais ils
n'ont pas réussi à
détruire à quelques cibles l équipe de
la biélorussie le may la meilleure récup
a montré aussi un résultat de vingt et
quelques minutes en détruisant tous les
cibles alors cette année est pour
effectuer en cire sur la cible numéro 12
les équipages auront trois missions et
ils ont du succès ils peuvent continuer
leur itinéraire sans boucles de pénalité
s'il y a une cible manquée à l'heure il
y aura des pénalités et seulement après
ces pénalités s'il ya toujours des
cibles qui n'ont pas été détruites
l'équipage va faire en boucle de
pénalité qui s'étend sur 500 m alors
chers amis je vous prie de nous excuser
notre tournoi va commencer et je vous
présente les équipages du premier tour
du biathlon de chars d'assaut de l'année
2020 à droite le char vers l'équipe de
la ve république populaire de chine
commandé par sergent jones en tireur 40
heures jude twingo et mécaniciens les
atteintes à leur applaudissait la chine
s'il vous plaît là
ensuite le shard ronge l la république d
azerbaïdjan commandait pas par culma met
du chrome à neuf tireurs punter mustapha
bayal maquette 10 nov
et dire conducteur oumar omarov
l'azerbaïdjan le sharp jaune l équipage
de la serbie
comment des parts lieutenant de chance
défense chef tireur nenad stojkovic et
mécaniciens conducteur sergent n'est
boschat maksimovic eux qui ont en charge
jaune sur la quatrième piste la
république de la biélorussie et le char
a commandé par ivan gosse un trip à
coulisser directeur pointer et
mécaniciens conducteur sergei konovalov
alors vous les biélorusses sont un char
de couleur bleue
[Musique]
alors tous les équipages sont des relais
chars ils peuvent commencer à concourir
et c'est le char vers la chine qui
commençait les premiers alors nous
sommes en direct de la chaîne sbs da et
moi je m'appelle nicolas et fedorov je
suis commentateurs de ce tournoi alors
le bientôt de chars 2020 débute d'ici
une seconde sur la commande du général
bye jeune romane been joukov
[Musique]
alors c'est l'équipe chinoise qui
commence la première vous pouvez voir
l'entraîneur de cette équipe est cher
ami est le premier obstacle c'est la
serpentine à l'heure ici et le
mécanicien conducteur du char doit être
très prudent on peut pas toucher à aucun
à aucune des bornes qui sont installés
sur la piste et s'il ya une infraction
alors que le charles devra être placé
sur la leyre de pénalité alors la chine
s'est acquitté de du premier obstacle
alors le char chinois ça fait pour
charger diminution alors il faut quitter
l'appareil et commencer à charger des
munitions vous pouvez voir que tous les
membres d'équipage a participé à cet
exercice
le commandant du char le pointeur tireur
et tous les autres participent à cet
exercice et en suisse car ensuite ils
continuent leur itinéraire et qu'il
commence mentir et sur la cible numéro
12 m étant elles peuvent commencer à le
moment maintenant le char est prêt à
accomplir les premières missions c'est
le kiri sur les cibles à partir de la
distance de 1600 1700 1800 mètres
maintenant c'est la règle d'asira gens
qui commencent à sa poursuite est
maintenant nous leur souhaitons la bonne
chance et c'est aussi la bonne chance à
monsieur bul m'hamed maintenant la cible
le tir est maintenant là l'équipe de
chine a détruit la cible qui est
complètement détruite à la distance de
1600 mètres maintenant nous avons la
deuxième cible sur le champ un travail
parfait du champ de tir dans la vie nos
de la région militaire de l'ouest
maintenant elle a fait une bonne
précision le est assurée par les pointer
la cible détruite
un travail brillant maintenant c'est
john thune peau qui fait et assure le
pointage
maintenant la troisième cible sur le
champ maintenant c'est l'équipage de
l'airbus de serbie qui commença sa
course du biathlon de chardin comment
maintenant et qui a fait lui tire tout à
l'heure maintenant chers amis il a fait
trois tirs et il a détruit trois cibles
bravo pour mir équipages de la chine
très bons résultats qui a démontré par
les pointeurs de la république populaire
de chine j'aimerais vous rappeler qu'il
utilise le prototype de chars de combat
t 90
est-ce maintenant les autres utilisent
le char de combat russes et des 72
maintenant au niveau des performances
techniques et tactiques
les équipes sont mixtes similaires
maintenant je propose de revenir un peu
plus tard aux performances mais je
propose de revenir sur le champ et
regarder l'équipe de la répudier repas
zhang qui a chargé et trois tirs et sont
en train de finir le moment sont prêts à
commencer le tenir trois cibles rouges
vont se lever à la distance de 1600 1700
1800 mètres la première cible et sur le
champ meta on attend avec impatience et
surtout ça concerne les supporters
d'azir badjan et qui sont à côté de leur
poste de télévision 24 contente de
regarder en direct sur la chaîne sbs
dame est dans le tir a été bien fait la
cible a été détruite ces messieurs
mustapha j'aimerais vous rappeler qui
est le résultat 22000 47 secondes qui a
permis de détruire les taux trois cibles
hills et ça va se passer un peu plus
tard maintenant le deuxième type est
assurée par le chat room qui a détruit
aussi la cible eux maintenant attention
sur le champ à la distance de 1800
mètres
la cible rouge l'équipage qui est
commandée par gama nagl mammadova de la
république d'azerbaïdjan
il faut se préparer il faut rester calme
avec un coeur toutefois pour être assuré
un bon tir en même temps c'est l'équipe
à de l'art comme de galles russie qui
commence la course une bonne chance le
troisième tir assuré par la diva gens
bien même main encore plus sa part fait
peuvent continuer le mouvement est sur
le bon club et maintenant c'est le char
avec le premier équipage de passe à une
grande vitesse
à côté c'est en même temps on a train de
regarder
on fait la premier relevé du temps qui a
fait cinq minutes neuf secondes serbie
et réussit aussi la première cible
numéro 12 pendant que l équipage et
chinois a fini à la première boucle avec
le récital de 5 minutes 35 secondes si
je me trompe pas maintenant attention la
cible de couleur jaune et c'est
l'équipage de serbie qui a fait le tir
de combat qui est le pointage est apte à
suivre épargna stojanovic la première
cible est détruite
le tir est fait maintenant la cible
détruite chers amis au bord deux beaux
et maintenant c'est l'arbitré en chef
qui fait lui jugement maintenant on va
regarder la répétition du deuxième tir
de la serbie pendant que c'est la
troisième ici bleus numéro 12 à la
distance de 1800 mètres et maintenant
voilà la troisième cible et covert
vraiment un passage brion tous les trois
équipages de l'azerbaïdjan de serbie de
la zero gens ont démontré les résultats
brillants et l'équipage de mobiles de
russie a fini et leur chargement de
munitions pour se préparer maintenant
c'est la répétition nous voyons que
c'est un le tir a touché en bas et c'est
un très bon résultat qui est fixé à part
des systèmes qui ne permet de dire que
la cible détruite c'est une énarque
stand qui a fait le tir de combat qui a
démontré un travail brillant maintenant
c'est le supporters serbes qui les
soutiennent maintenant on
32 revenir vers l'équipage de
biélorussie maintenant le premier tir
pour le premier équipage à qui a détruit
à la cible eux maintenant la deuxième à
cible et sur le champ c'est andré paccou
les qui le pointeur de ce char
maintenant attention la troisième cible
va apparaître d'ici quelques secondes
maintenant la distance de 1800 mètres je
vous rappelle anne ray pacolli on va
voir s'il réussi ou non
nous voyons que seul le personnel
d'entraîneurs qui sont impatients parce
que tout le monde et en émotions et
c'est l'équipage de l'airbus naseba 30 à
32 finir le premier tour de la course
individuelle maintenant avec le résultat
de six minutes 25 secondes qui t'a
retard d'une minute et 15 secondes par
rapport à la chine et l'équipe de
biélorussie est assez bien préparés ils
sont en train de se pointer pour ne pas
rater la cible et quand vous voyez ils
n'ont pas commis d'erreur il on attend
les 3es cible le travail les brayons
tous les quatre équipages ont bien
travaillé avec un score parfait et
maintenant c'est l'équipe chinoise qui
accomplit la deuxième mission de ti on
va vouloir sur la répétition
il s'agit de la discussion d'une cible
imitant un hélicoptère à la distance de
900 mètres à partir du mitrailleuses
anti-aériennes de 13,7 mm une fois que
la cible numéro 13 est détruit d' un feu
est allumé pour confirmer le fait que le
commandant
duscher a bien accompli sa mission grâce
à aux légendes qui apparaissait sur
l'écran nous pouvons avoir plus
d'information maintenant le premier
drapeau qui est monté par l'équipage du
char jaunes sont observés en même temps
par les arbitres qui se trouvera dans
tous les commandes du chant maintenant
132 finir l'après-midi boucle avec un
résultat de sept minutes 4 secondes qui
t'a retard par rapport la chine d'une
minute de 54 secondes
pendant que la typage serbe a s'est
classé à la troisième place on a train
de regarder à la partie droite de
l'écran on peut voir la vitesse de
jusqu'à 60 kilomètres de l'équipage
chinois sur une partie tout directeur
on se rappellera corps dernier
maintenant elle et 32 passes et le gué
kit assurée par le conducteur du char de
4,96 bay est maintenant les supporters
de la république qui populaire de chine
et sont ravis
maintenant l'équipage chinois doit
passer encore trois obstacles pourraient
finaliser la deuxième boucle afin de
passer la troisième mission de tir de
combat
maintenant on voit que le char rouget
pendant le passage d'un terrain occident
t-130 de toucher à une scarpe par les
airs badges ont maintenant ils seront
obligés de passer par une aire de
pénalités sont en train de charger les
munitions et c'est le compte de
chat qui vient de le faire dans ce
métrage aux anti aériennes et qui est
monté sur les chars t-72 b qui sont
fournis par la partie russe à
l'exception de la l'équipage net chinois
et à l'accession de la république de
biélorussie qui ont les mêmes chars mais
qui sont utilisées par les forces armées
de la république maintenant c'est la
cible numéro 25 et sur le chante pour
l'azerbaïdjan le premier équipage un
train de faire le tir et c'est dumas
mais de gamme arnova quitte à 30 de
faire le tir
[Musique]
afin d'assurer le tir sur la cible une
urne dans sa cale de capteurs ont fourni
25 des cartouches
il comprit hsieh avec les bals être en
santé oms pour l'instant on voit pas de
feux allumés ce qui ne permet de dire
vraisemblablement qu'il n'arrive pas à
faire de ti réussi en parlant de
l'équipe à de l'asf badge en ce qui
concerne surtout à la réalisation de
cette mission maintenant le feu talent
mais la cible est atteinte
un travail parfait on peut veut
continuer leur mouvement et sur le tracé
a même temps à l'équipe de serbie vient
de s'arrêter pour accomplir la même
mission qui a été assurée tout à l'heure
par l'équipage de la république et d'
azerbaïdjan c'est vraiment parfait parce
que personne n'a fait deux tours de
pénalité
actuellement on a fixé les manques
commun que mon essai il s'agit de
passage de lescar pas par l'équipe de
l'azerbaïdjan et les arbitres vont
définir à l'air de pénalité par laquelle
doivent pas ça même temps l'équipe de la
république de biélorussie s'approche de
l'air pour accomplir la deuxième
émission qui se trouvaient sur les
scalps c'est vraiment rennes obstacle
difficile qui est un obstacle qui fait
80 et 10 cm evian de réussir ce passage
maintenance la cible jaune pour l'équipe
peut servir ses monastères nowitzki et
faire le pointage mettant un peu velay
cible détruite
maintenant c'est la cible numéro 25
hélicoptères qui est démontrée sur
l'écran c'est la cible 25 qui imite le
cocktail qui vole à une basse altitude
et demi et qui sait assez vraiment réel
de le détruire à partir d'une
mitrailleuse montait
sur un char de calais ou de 12 7 mai le
m chers amis élèves étaient de 70 km
heure c'est vraiment la meilleure dit
est ce qui a été démontré par l'équipage
de la république d'azerbaïdjan
maintenant je vous propose de regarder
les actions de l'équipage de la chine et
qui agissent et situe face aux super
vite et il s'arrête et le prennent les
munitions et il se prépare à continuer
le mouvement maintenant le char bleus
est préparé mais ça c'est le commandant
du shaq qui va faire le tueur c'est ivan
goût ce qui va assurer le tir
la cible est sur le champ nous voyons
comment la mitrailleuse et un axiome
maintenant la cible d'attentats elle
peut continuer de cette façon le
mouvement peuvent vous rappelle qu'on
tue et le moment une fois que le
commande de chars fait le rapport à la
tour d'arbitrage que la cible détruite
et en même temps l'équipage de l'équipe
de la république populaire de chine qui
a détruit la cible numéro 9 fait on
propose de regarder la répétition qui
simule le lance-grenades lance-roquettes
antichars rpg avec une mitrailleuse de
coop ciel de kalou de 7,62 mm à la
légende un graphique et démontre le
mouvement de l'équipage et chinois je
demande pardon chers amis il reste jour
sur sa position
elle est toujours à l'arrêt
je je me suis dépêché tu peux en même
temps continue le tir ils ont encore des
munitions qui sont disponibles chez les
pointeurs de l'équipe chinoise pour
rassurer le tirer sur la cible numéro 9
un très bon passage de l'obstacle nommé
gay qui démontré par le char jaune de
serbie qui est conduit par une ébauche
maksimovic r maintenant ils passent à
côté de supporters a maintenant la
relever du thon fait de 14 minutes 48
secondes qui est pratiquement retard de
trois minutes par rapport la chine
c'est vraiment être un passage est très
dangereux
c'était vraiment très très dangereux il
faut rester quand même plus prudent à
pour éviter d'être ma parce qu'en même
temps que tout le monde veut passer le
plus vite possible mais ce noble tacle
très dangereux qui est assuré par
messieurs gribben quo mais temps c'est
assez compliqué parce que le véhicule va
faire des mouvements à gauche et à
droite parce qu'ils doivent passer à
l'écart de toutes les mines a placé
maintenant attention le caméra à
l'intérieur du char à ses homards au
maroc le mécanicien du char de l'équipe
de l'azerbaïdjan qui est sur le
mouvement et mettant c'est l'entraîneur
qui sur l'écran avec les supporters qui
est sera vide qui est se tiennent elles
leur équipe est maintenant il est nous
aliments de l'énergie aie pas la chaleur
de leur coeur pour supporter à leurs
gains
leur équipe est tout ce qu'ils
affrontent de regarder en direct sur
l'internet qui nous regardent sur le
poste de télévision qui est assurée par
la chaîne sbs d'art maintenant c'est la
première course du bataillon de chars
maintenance et la serbie qu'elle assume
position de tir à la tente du deuxième
tour chez à me regardait qu'elle est
bonne les répétitions qui a été
démontrée tout à l'heure pendant le
passage du gué qui a été fait par la
chine qui est pratiquement rentrée et
d'équité de la même façon en tant que
pierre lancée dans l'eau un bon travail
sur et par les mécaniciens de ce char
n'équipe pas j'ai bien préparé et
vraisemblablement l'équipe chinoise a
prises en compte les erreurs de l'année
précédente
et maintenant on voit que le char jaune
doit bien passé à l'écart de mines entre
les chu ni et maintenant c'est le char
bleus et la serbie est en train de finir
le deuxième tour il quitte en retard par
rapport la chine du 1er étage de deux
minutes 13 secondes
attention et la biélorussie pendant le
passage des obstacles respecte d'abord
la prudence mettant cette munition
conducteur de servier et konovalovas de
biélorussie qui est montré ça y est tous
les pitots de regard de toute la
biélorussie à de soutien et les faux cul
tu assures bon compte du sien maintenant
à l'équipage et chinois l'équipe
chinoise a défini le premier tour avec
19 minutes 20 secondes c'est les
résultats de l'équipe chinoise
je propose de faire la comparaison avec
l'année précédente
ce 18 minutes et 57 secondes maintenant
c'est
qui est permis quand même de détruire
toutes les cibles et ils ont évité les
airs et les tours de pénalité on
continue la télévision en direct sur la
chaîne sbs da maintenant c'est nicolas
vidéo qui fait part de ses commentaires
pendant que l'équipage de la république
d'azerbaïdjan qui a continué à accomplir
sa mission maintenant le chair rouge
détruit complètement la cible numéro 9
vraiment c'est extraordinaire qui ce qui
est démontré par l'équipe asia pas de
neige pas ce que l'année précédente qui
a pris la quatrième place qui a été
avant leurs collègues chinois
maintenant nous voyons très bien que
tous les équipages sont très bien
préparés maintenant c'est l'équipe de
biélorussie qui grimpe très facilement
c'est la crème pages déchirées par t-72
b3
il ya de la russie continue son moment
pour faire le tir lui sur la tib le
numéro 9 allée distance de 600 m
maintenant c'est la cible numéro 9
alors l'équipage serbe est prête à
effectuer du tir vous pouvez voir aussi
l'équipe d'azerbaïjan et maintenant vous
voyez la sélection serbe un petit souci
au niveau de la sélection serbe
il s'agit d'une infraction évidente des
règles de ceux qui pètent s on peut pas
faire tourner la tourelle pendant le tir
de combat mais dieu merci les munitions
ne sont pas chargés dans ce cas non
alors
le temps passe maintenant nous allons
regarder le tir effectué pas prêt
biélorusses dont vous pouvez voir que
l'entraîneur de l'équipe
il a dit que l'équipe est prête à tirer
il s'agit d'une un mythe faille aux
échos axial de calibre de 7,62 mm et qui
peut qui capable et détection des tirs
jusqu'à 1800 m donc le tireur pointer
détecte la cible et commencent à
chiffrer
les cibles sont faits de verre est même
s'il y a une soeur balki
touche la cible elle vole en éclats
voilà vous pouvez voir maintenant en
fait pas coulisses qui a atteint sa
cible
et voilà maintenant à le char près
continuer à l'équipe de biélorussie a
dépensé 18 minutes à l'heure vous avez
un peu rude minutes pour devancer
l'équipe de la chine qui se classe
première a pour l'instant bien
évidemment non supportant toutes les
équipes mais c'est très intéressant de
voir la lutte entre toutes les équipes
qui conteste le leadership de ce tournoi
voilà vous pouvez voir andré paccou
liste qui vient de l'effectif sentir sur
la cible alors on va voir quelle est la
vitesse à laquelle va se charge à 50
kilomètres par heure maintenant c'est
déjà 60 l'an dernier les russes on
établi un record mondial de 84
kilomètres heure alors toutes les
équipes n'ont pas encore reçu deux
boucles de pénalité mais il s'agit de
savoir quel est le souci auquel est
confronté sont confrontés les serbes et
voilà la chine se classe premier et
ensuite vous pouvez le voir
l'azerbaïdjan qui figeait qui arrive
deuxième avec l'en deux minutes trente
et une secondes
je vous rappelle que le temps que nous
contrôlons ici peut-être différent parce
que chaque arbitre assez prompt à sa
propre montre de contrainte de contrôler
et après la consultation de l'ensemble
des arbitres elle le temps final va être
très déterminé
alors chers amis
donc vingt deux minutes et trente et une
secondes c'est le temps d'intervalle
gens nous salon l'équipe azéri ils ont
bien fait ils ont fait du joli travail
là vous voyez les biélorusses qui
traverse le guet il le fait exprès mais
vite et bien évidemment cet exercice
exige le maximum
des formes de la part de l'ensemble de
l'équipage qui est composé de trois
personnes mais en fait c'est pas prêt
puisque le shark
c'est un attrait vivant il a sonam lui
aussi lui aussi les participer à ce
dialogue
alors il cette équipe est traversé la
colline et maintenant c'est le phocéa
anti char qu'ils doivent surmonter
il faut avoir une bonne vision et éviter
que le char quitte son itinéraire et je
rappelle que ce char pèse 42 tonnes
alors l'arbitré jette monte monte le
drapeau blanc il n'y a pas eu de
d'infractions sur cette partie sur ce
tronçon de la piste
et voilà le char de l'équipe biélorusse
traverse le fossé entier chaque sans
toucher aux poteaux
il ya des poteaux qui sont placés sur
terre et d'autres sont suspendus alors
mais le conducteur de l'équipe de la
biopsie a très bien fait et ce chaque
termine cette course avec 21 une minute
57 secondes et ce qui les amène à la
deuxième position et je vous rappelle
que l'an dernier
les biélorusses ont montré les résultats
de vente et une minute 22 secondes tout
en effectuant avec succès le dire sur
l'ensemble des cibles
donc ceci est devenu possible grâce à la
conservation des efforts de tous les
membres de cette équipe
maintenant vous pouvez voir sur l'écran
la serbie et qui finalement
a continué sa course on sait pas
pourquoi les raisons de leur arrêt mais
la cible n'a pas été atteinte donc le
premier équipage de la sélection serbe a
dû procéder à une boucle de pénalité
dans que nous avons deux tours de
pénalité pour que les équipages puisse
s'acquitter de l'ale de leurs pénalités
dusan stevan chef commandant de chars
que vous pouvez voir actuellement sur
vos écrans
la république de serbie il ya peut-être
et on peut être d'émotion peut-être
qu'il ya eu un problème technique ce
sont les arbitres qui vont s'occuper de
cette investigation ainsi que le groupe
d'accompagnement et d'assistance
technique et le verdict sera rendu
aujourd'hui à l'issue du collège
d'arbitré alors ils terminent leurs
boucles de pénalité deux pénalités lors
lité c'est plus de 65km a peur c'est une
très belle des pièces d'ailleurs et
cette année comme j'ai déjà dit il y a
eu des changements dans notre tournoi et
c'est particulier concernant la première
division si une cible mais pas attentes
notamment la cible numéro 12 l'équipage
devra utiliser des munitions
supplémentaires faut dépenser le temps
supplémentaire et de notamment ce qui a
une incidence sur leur résultat final
les cibles qui imitent les chars ont été
atteints aujourd'hui donc nous n'avons
pas pu voir ce changement en qualité
aujourd'hui nous souhaiterions que
toutes les séries toutes les tours soit
aussi éclatant est intéressant comme
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas toujours
le cas
chers amis
demain nous aurons deux tours de notre
pour toi à 11 heures il y aura la
première série pour la deuxième division
de la seconde division
ensuite le deuxième série mai à 15
heures il
on va vous montrer les capacités des
armements de ce matériel de guerre qui
est utilisé par les forces armées de
russie
aujourd'hui nous allons célébrer le jour
des troupes de charges et donc on va
voir ce qu'ils peuvent se montrer
alors on prend ce
sion du char ensuite il reprend sa place
et voilà nous voyons que ce char a
touché un poteau et c'est pour cette
raison qu'ils doivent dépenser du temps
supplémentaire à une r1 un air de
pénalité mais quand même les serbes
auront démontré un bon résultat ils ont
eu un problème sur la position du tir
numéro 3 mais c'est le sport est tout et
qui est le sport qui est imprévisible
alors chers amis maintenant nous voyons
applaudissez et l'équipage de serbes qui
nous a montré aujourd'hui de très belles
performances tout leur préparation
s'était dit entourent très intéressant
les arbitres games internationale c'est
que vous avez pu saisir c'est suivre
grâce à nicolet fedorov et la chaîne
vsda alors je vous souhaite plein succès
au nom du ministère de la défense de la
fédération de russie qui est toujours à
vos côtés